用声音 碰撞世界 生动活泼。
生动早咖啡 与你轻松同步日常生活与商业世界。
嗨各位 早上好呀 今天是2026年的5月8号星期五。
这里是生动早咖啡 我是来自生动活泼的梦一。
存储芯片的长假潮 给三星带来了怎样的影响。
为什么科技公司 都会用游戏来训练AI。
今天节目的上半部分 就会来回答这些问题。
那在今天节目后半段的咖啡豆回复时间里。
要来回复一位 和我们的监制有着同样名字的听友Stella。
这位Stella说 自己是一个咖啡爱好者 很喜欢买咖啡豆。
不过她发现一个奇怪的现象。
她说不管是在外卖平台 电商平台。
还是连锁咖啡品牌的小程序里 很多咖啡豆。
不管是什么产地或者是品牌 都会声称自己是得了金奖的豆子。
Stella就很好奇 这些金奖都是真的吗？
这个奖到底是怎么评选出来的。
为什么感觉满大街的咖啡豆 都能够拿到金奖呢？
我们在几条简短的商业科技动态之后。
马上就会和你一起来聊聊 咖啡行业的金奖到底是怎么回事。
三星宣布退出中国家电市场。
5月6号 三星在官网发布公告。
他们决定 停止在中国大陆市场。
销售包含电视显示器在内的所有家电产品。
但是手机产品仍然会正常销售。
彩星认为三星家电曾经是中国市场的高端霸主。
但是随着中国家电市场增量触顶。
海信 TCL 等等本土品牌崛起。
三星的品牌溢价逐渐难以维持。
数据显示从今年年初到4月以来。
三星在中国线下市场采电销售额的占比。
还不到4% 冰箱洗衣机的份额则不到0.5%。
另外受到存储芯片涨价的影响。
他们的家电业务还拖累了三星集团整体的盈利表现。
他们开始实施业务聚焦策略。
退出中国家电市场就是举措之一。
不过三星也受益于AI对于存储芯片的需求。
同一天他们的股价上涨超过14%。
成为台积电之后第二家市值突破万亿美元的亚洲公司。
月之暗面在不到半年时间里完成了第四轮融资。
根据晚点5月6号的报道。
AI模型公司月之暗面即将完成新一轮20亿美元的融资。
头后估值将会突破200亿美元。
今年1月和2月他们刚刚密集完成了三轮融资。
目前月之暗面的累计融资额已经超过了376亿人民币。
成为大模型出创公司当中融资最多的公司。
晚点指出月之暗面曾经在2024年进行大额投放。
当时的产品也比较发散包括海外2C产品和视频生成。
随后到2025年的春节市场注意力都几乎被GipSig吸引。
月之暗面也做出了相应调整。
他们将持续拿到模型最佳表现作为优先级最高的目标。
大幅减少C端投放从B元走向开源。
并且更加聚焦持续强化模型的编程和智能体能力。
今年以来他们的收入和订阅用户数大幅增长。
不过月之暗面现在也在面临着人才压力。
他们的员工成为了竞争对手的重点挖角对象。
公司创始人杨直林也在全员信中提到。
2026年公司平均激励将是2025年的200%。
并且计划大幅上调7权回购的额度。
Google DeepMind利用游戏训练AI。
5月6号Google DeepMind宣布。
将收购游戏EVE Online开发商的少数股权。
利用这款游戏来训练AI技术。
根据彭布社的报道EVE Online。
是一款大型多人在线角色扮演游戏。
玩家可以进行创建团队、贸易等等活动。
能够帮助AI在长期规划和持续学习能力上取得进步。
此前Google DeepMind。
已经通过星际争霸等等多款游戏来训练AI。
由于游戏提供了一个规则清晰反馈及时。
还可以无限生成数据的虚拟世界。
它也被认为是训练AI的理想场景。
Anthopen将会从SpaceX获得算力。
5月6日，美国AI公司Anthopen宣布。
与马斯克旗下的SpaceX达成协议。
将获得SpaceX超算集群ClosestOne的所有算力。
这座超算集群搭载了22万张英伟达GPU。
算力规模达到300兆瓦。
Anthopen在算力池大幅扩容之后。
还宣布减少用户的使用限制。
TechCrunch认为，SpaceX在2月收购了XAI并且进行了重组。
多位XAI的核心成员陆续出走。
他们的主要产品，聊天机器人Grogg的使用量。
也在不断的下降
由于算力是开发AI产品必不可少的资源。
SpaceX与Anthopy的合作。
可能说明XAI正在转型成为一家算力提供商。
以上就是我们编辑部为你整理的几条商业科技动态。
下面和我一同走进到今天的咖啡豆回复时间。
欢迎来到由图拉斯赞助的每周五咖啡豆回复时间。
今天我们要来聊一个真的和咖啡豆相关的话题。
我们的听优斯特拉发现很多品牌的咖啡豆。
都标榜自己是得了金奖的豆子。
他很好奇为什么有这么多的咖啡豆品牌都能获奖。
我们这位听优的观察还是很敏锐的。
当你打开锐信库迪或者是罗马咖啡的点摊小程序。
一个IIAC金奖的标志确实随处可见。
无论是这些连锁咖啡品牌。
还是股民护上阿姨这些想要跨界进入咖啡赛道的奶茶品牌。
甚至是麦当劳华来市这些快餐品牌。
都在宣传自己使用的是IIAC金奖咖啡豆。
那我们就先来看一下IIAC到底是什么？
它的全称是International Institute of Coffee Tasters。
进过来也就是国际咖啡品件协会。
它的官网信息显示。
这个组织是1993年在意大利成立的。
也是一个非盈利组织。
靠的是会员费来运营。
这个协会开发了一套通过感官。
去客观评价咖啡的方法。
而IIAC这个协会主办的比赛叫做ICT。
也就是International Coffee Tasting国际咖啡品件比赛。
在2006年第一次举办。
这个比赛采用的是匿名盲色的形式。
基于协会开发的方法对咖啡来进行打分。
最终通过统计公事计算得出成绩。
在ICT的比赛当中只设立了金奖和博金奖。
并没有设立赢奖和统奖。
而想要获得这个协会的金奖需要满足两个条件。
第一个条件是在满分100分的成绩计算当中。
得分要在85分以上。
第二个条件是要成为这场品件会。
排名前25的产品。
而这前25%获得金奖的咖啡中。
前20%的咖啡有资格进入博金奖的掘足。
而且想要报名参加这个比赛的流程也并不是很复杂。
品牌方需要首先向IIAC提交报名信息。
缴纳每款产品2000人民币左右的参赛费。
然后按照要求寄送咖啡样品。
除了咖啡豆
IIAC品选的产品范围还包括了交囊咖啡。
挂耳咖啡等等不同的产品。
尽管每个品牌
每年最多可以选择10款产品去参赛。
但是协会设置了阶梯制的报名费的标准。
参赛的咖啡产品越多。
平均下来
每款产品的报名费还会更便宜。
其他一些在咖啡行业媒体中。
经常出现的咖啡赛事和IIAC不同。
因为他们往往会有更多伦次的筛选机制。
比如Couple of Excellence 也就是卓越杯。
参与这个比赛的是咖啡豆的众职者。
而比赛的对象是咖啡生豆。
每场比赛有几百种不同的咖啡豆参赛。
经过多轮比赛的筛选和淘汰。
最终只有不到30种咖啡豆。
能够获得卓越杯的称号。
而且这个比赛还会有机构。
组织专门的拍卖会。
那些获得了卓越杯称号的咖啡豆。
往往会比普通咖啡豆。
贵上几倍 甚至是几十倍。
另外行业里还有针对咖啡师个人的比赛。
WBC 也就是世界咖啡师警标赛。
这个比赛比的是咖啡师的水平。
选手需要在规定时间内。
完成多杯咖啡的制作。
而且也必须在赢得自己国家的比赛冠军之后。
才能够去参加全球范围的比赛。
那对比不同的比赛我们也可以发现。
在国内各个平台上都能够看到的。
IIAC 金奖咖啡豆。
对于参赛者并没有筛选的机制。
任何品牌只要缴纳了报名费。
寄送样品就能够参赛。
而针对生豆的卓越杯。
或者是咖啡师之间的比赛。
都是需要经过多轮的淘汰。
而且同一个品牌在参与IIAC的金奖评选时。
可以最多让自己的10款产品去参加比赛。
有行业媒体认为
IIAC的金奖本质上是一个合格线以上的认证等级。
而不是淘汰至竞赛的名次。
像是星巴克、AMSTEM。
还有Manacoffee等的品牌。
就很少在产品或者是包装上。
标注IIAC这类赛事的奖项。
那为什么国内还是会有很多的品牌。
会强调自己的产品获得了这个金奖呢？
原因之一
瑞幸的示范效应
ICT也就是刚刚我们所提到的。
国际咖啡品件比赛。
早期的参与者
都是以欧洲的咖啡烘焙商为主的。
后来才扩展到了亚洲。
2017年ICT的比赛在广州举办。
当时来自北京、广州。
香港还有澳门的品牌获得了金奖。
如果翻看历年的获奖名单。
你会发现
瑞幸是国内第一家。
参加这个比赛的大新联所咖啡品牌。
他们从2018年就开始参赛。
一直到2025年。
他们每年都获得了金奖。
这几年瑞幸在全国门店。
和自己的小程序上。
也在大规模推广这个金奖的标签。
有行业媒体认为
在瑞幸的示范之下。
从2021年开始。
参与比赛的中国企业。
开始大量的增加
有些企业为了提高获奖几率。
往往会按照比赛的上限。
同时选择10款产品去参赛。
像是库迪在2024年就一口气。
拿了7项金奖
罗瓦咖啡也把金奖标志。
放到了几乎所有
他们主打的银品详情页上。
七仙咖啡 幸运咖等等品牌。
也都纷纷宣布
使用了IAC金奖豆。
从2020年开始。
ICT的比赛从单次集中评审。
也改成了全年多场次。
在不同国家举办比赛。
从2024年8月开始。
IAC在国内累计举办了。
十多场的ICT赛事。
我们以去年12月的一场比赛为例。
当时一共有40多款咖啡。
获得了金奖
其中既有瑞幸这样的老玩家。
也有肯德基 奥勒奇。
超市这些咖啡领域的跨界选手。
还有来自国内的一些。
咖啡烘焙商
很多品牌和咖啡店。
即便自己没有去参加比赛。
他们也能够去购买。
这些获得了金奖的豆子。
原因之二
金奖是一个性价比很高的。
营销手段
按照IAC的规则。
品牌付费参赛
每年最多送凭十款产品。
加起来的报名费
也只有一万多人民币。
而动不动上百万的。
广告投放费用相比。
一个国际赛事的金奖标签。
品牌宣传效果可能会更好。
我们以京东自营品牌的。
一款咖啡豆为例
在京东APP上
选择按照销量排名之后。
你会发现
排名第一的
是一款号称
拿到了94分的金奖豆。
这款咖啡豆
要比同样是京东的品牌。
但是标注了产地
烘焙程度
或者是风味的咖啡豆。
销量更多
其实类似的现象
在同样强调产地
工艺和风味的
葡萄酒领域
也出现过
澳大利亚
一位专门研究
葡萄酒营销的学者。
曾经进行过
一系列的实验
他想要测试
品牌 产地 价格。
还有奖项
对于消费者
购买决策时候的影响。
他发现
同样一瓶酒
在被贴上京奖的标签之后。
被消费者选择的概率。
会大幅提升
影响决策的力度
甚至要比其他几个因素更强。
而像是
瑞幸 库狄 肯德基的咖啡单价。
大多在几块钱
到十几块钱之间
大多数的消费者
购买这类咖啡的时候。
往往也是出于
提升行脑的目的
并不会在意
咖啡豆的产地
或者是处理方式
而京奖的标签
可以帮助消费者
快速做出一个
这看起来不会出错的选择。
有行业媒体认为
IIAC与品牌没有利益关联。
认证的可信度
要高于咖啡企业的自我宣传。
所以也会有不少的品牌。
会将获得京奖作为卖点。
以此来吸引消费者。
那你平时买咖啡的时候。
会特别留意
包装上标的各种
讲相认证吗？
像是京奖之类的标签。
会影响你的消费决策吗？
欢迎在评论区
和我们一起来聊聊。
那在今天节目的最后。
还想和你来分享一下。
我们咖啡豆恢复时间的一个。
小小变化
在今年接下来的时间里。
每周五的咖啡豆恢复时间。
都会有土拉斯的特别赞助。
相信大家也已经在。
今天的节目中听到了。
土拉斯鼓励大家
随时随地记录生活。
探索生活
勇敢表达自我的主张。
和我们的咖啡豆恢复。
环节不谋而合
我们都期待大家能够。
多观察身边那些
有趣的商业现象
并将你的发现
和好奇分享出来
那么从现在开始
只要你的投稿
能被节目组选中
成为每周五的咖啡豆选题。
你就能获得
由土拉斯送出的礼品一份。
投稿方式
可以在早咖啡
主页的公告栏里找到。
记得留好联系方式。
方便我们联系到你。
另外
在每周五的节目
shownotes。
也就是单级简介中。
你还能看到
土拉斯最新的品牌动态。
欢迎关注
早咖啡的社群活动。
也同步升级了
参与每周的
咖啡豆风味回顾活动。
赢得积分
每个月也有机会
抽取土拉斯的
专属奖励
还没进行的朋友
欢迎在单级简介中。
添加声响音的企业微信。
快来参与吧？